Okay, if you attempted to solve this, you should have gotten these as your
factored fractions. Now there's a lot of missing work in between. You needed to
change division to multiplication and take the reciprocal of that second
fraction. I'm not going to show you all the factoring for each of these, but
hopefully you can figure it out. In the end, we can simplify the factors a plus
7, 3a plus 2, and 2a minus 5. This leaves us with our answer, 4a minus 3
divided by 3a minus 4. You want to be really careful at the end here, as well.
These last two factors have different coefficients for the a. One is 4, and one
is 3. You might think that these are opposite polynomials, but we know that's
not true since the a's have different coefficients, and the constants are
different as well. We can't simplify these at all, so we'll leave this as our
answer.